أعلام ترفرف في نصف الصاري في الحي الأرميني
من المدينة القديمة في القدس
حيث أحيت خدمات الكنيسة الخاصة
ذكرى الفظائع التي ارتكبت منذ أكثر من قرن من الزمان
بعد سنوات عديدة جاء يوم الذكرى
هذا بأمل تحقق
الاعتراف الأمريكي بمجتمع
الإبادة الجماعية الأرمينية
قال المؤرخ جورج هنتليون ،
الذي كان والديه لاجئين في
أحداث عنف عام 1915 ، إن إعلان بايدن هو
تتويج الرئيس لقد تصرف بايدن بروح
الآباء المؤسسين لأمريكا وأعتقد أن
هذا سيؤثر
أكثر من تركيا لمواجهة
ماضيها ، حيث تتبع الأرمن
وصولهم  هنا يعود إلى القرن الرابع الميلادي
حوالي 10000 شخص من أصل أرمني
يعيشون في إسرائيل
مع حوالي ألفي منهم في
القدس جزء من خليط معقد
من المجتمعات المسيحية الأرثوذكسية
التي جعلت منزلها في المدينة
لأكثر من ألف عام
للكنيسة الإسرائيلية من
أجل  كان إعلان الناشط الأرميني الإسرائيلي هاروت باراميان بايدن مرًا لأنه كان
حلوًا
ومرًا  لقد توقفت الحكومة الإسرائيلية
عن الاعتراف بالمجازر على أنها
إبادة جماعية
أنا أدعو إسرائيل إلى
أن تنحي السياسة جانباً ، فهذا لا
علاقة له بالسياسة ، إنه
التزام أخلاقي لإسرائيل
بالاعتراف بالإبادة الجماعية على أنها إبادة جماعية
أه مجدداً أه لمنعها من  يحدث
ذلك مرة
أخرى وكذلك احترامًا
لذكرى ضحايا الهولوكوست
وضحايا الإبادة الجماعية لأرمن ،
يأتي هذا الإعلان في
وقت مهم جدًا بالنسبة
للجالية الأرمينية في القدس
ليس فقط هو الذكرى 106
لتلك المجازر الجماعية.
تعترف إدارة الدراجات بأنها
إبادة جماعية ،
فقد جاءت أيضًا قبل يوم واحد من يوم
الأحد من النخيل الأرميني
، بداية أقدس أسبوع
للمجتمع الأرميني هنا في القدس ،
وهو أسبوع مقدس لأقدم مجتمع الشتات الأرميني الذي
يتميز الآن بالأمل في أن الإعلان الأمريكي
سيؤدي إلى المزيد  عدالة
هداس ذهب القدس